>> Tucker: RECENTLY
HILLARY CLINTON SAID THAT BRETT
KAVANAUGH COULD NOT BE ALLOWED
ON THE SUPREME COURT.
WE HAD TO BELIEVE HIS ACCUSER
SHE SAID, EVEN WITHOUT EVIDENCE.
IT WASN'T TOO SURPRISING THAT ON
SUNDAY SHE BACKTRACKED AND SHE
TOLD CBS THAT HER OWN HUSBAND
HAD NO OBLIGATION TO RESIGN OVER
THE MONICA LEWINSKY SCANDAL.
>> SOME TODAY HAD SAID HE SHOULD
HAVE STEPPED DOWN.
>> IN RETROSPECT, DO YOU THINK
BILL SHOULD HAVE RESIGNED IN THE
WAKE OF THE MONICA LEWINSKY
SCANDAL?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> WASN'T AN ABUSE OF POWER?
>> NO.
PEOPLE SAY PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CANNOT HAVE A
CONSENSUAL RELATIONSHIP WITH AN
INTERN, THE POWER IMBALANCES TOO
MUCH.
>> SHE WAS AN ADULT.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, WHERE'S THE
INVESTIGATION?
>> Tucker: EVEN THE LADIES OF
THE VIEW ARE NOT BUYING THIS
LINE OF ARGUMENT, AND SAID THEY
RIPPED HILLARY CLINTON BELIEVE
IT OR NOT FOR HER ABRASIVE
INTERVIEW TACTICS.
>> WHAT SHE JUST SAID IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE REPUBLICANS DO, THEY
CHANGE THE SUBJECT.
THAT IS WHY WE NEVER GET
ANYWHERE IN THE UTERUS.
>> YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
BAD
ARGUMENT WHEN YOUR MEETING
ARGUMENT IS, THEY ARE WORSE.
SHE CAN HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
KATHLEEN WIDELY CLAIMS THE
CLINTONS TRIED TO INTIMIDATE
HER.
SHE CALLED MONICA LEWINSKY AND
ARE         A
NARCISSIST.
THEY HAVE TO MOVE ON.
>> Tucker: CAMILLE POLLY IS AN
AUTHOR AND A CULTURAL CRITIC,
SHE HAS WRITTEN EXTENSIVELY
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
HER LATEST BOOK IS TITLED
"PROVOCATIONS."
SHE JOINS US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: HILLARY CLINTON IS
MENTIONED ON THIS BOOK.
LET ME ASK YOU SOME BROADER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS COUNTRY,
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO HER
ROLE AND THE KIND OF ME TOO
MOVEMENT?
>> IT IS VERY AMBIGUOUS.
I THINK HER HISTORY HAS BEEN
HYPOCRITICAL.
I WAS THE ONLY DEMOCRAT FEMINIST
TO CALL FOR BILL CLINTON'S
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        I
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        V
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        T
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        D
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        F
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        R
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        H
RESIGNATION AND DEVOTED        M
TWICE.
ALL THIS WAS HAPPENING, THE
SERVICING OF HIM BY AND ENTER IN
IN THE WHITE HOUSE OFFICES.
>> Tucker: IT IS A GOOD POINT
IN A GOOD REMINDER.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS WRITTEN ABOUT
SEX, GENDER ROLES, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THE CONVULSION WE ARE
GOING TO PARTICULARLY OF THE ME
TOO MOVEMENT?
>> IT IS GREAT, THAT ATTENTION
IS BEING MADE TO THE WOMEN BEING
ABUSE.
I WAS LOBBYING FOR MODERATE
HARASSMENT GUIDELINES IN MY
UNIVERSITY IN PHILADELPHIA.
I THINK WE HAVE GONE A LITTLE
BIT TOO FAR HERE.
FOLLOWING THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, THEY HAVE TO BE
CONSIDERED.
WHAT I AM SAY AS A FEMINIST IS
THAT WOMEN THEMSELVES MUST TAKE
CHARGE OF THEIR OWN INTERACTIONS
WITH MEN.
THEY MUST SIGNAL AT THE TIME
THAT SOMETHING IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THIS WAITING TEN YEARS, 20
YEARS, 30 YEARS, IT IS NOT
AMERICAN, IT IS STALINIST.
>> Tucker: WOMEN WERE TOLD
AGAIN AND AGAIN BY PEOPLE WHO
CLAIMED TO EMPOWER WOMEN ARE
THEMSELVES POWERLESS AND THEY
CAN'T SAY ANYTHING BECAUSE THEY
ARE SO LACKING IN POWER.
>> NONSENSE.
WORKING-CLASS WOMEN, YES.
MAY BE DEPENDENT ON A JOB THAT
THEY CANNOT PROTEST BUT AS I'VE
WRITTEN THERE ARE NO EXCUSES FOR
WELL EDUCATED UPPER-MIDDLE-CLASS
PROFESSIONAL WOMEN TO LET
OFFENSES TO THEIR DIGNITY GO BY.
YOU MUST DRAW THE LINE WHEN IT
HAPPENS.
IT IS ABSURD THAT YOU FEEL TOO
POWERLESS.
YOU CAN'T COMPLAIN.
WOMEN WHO SAY THAT ARE SIMPLY
PUTTING THE CAREER ADVANTAGE
OVER THE LARGER QUESTION OF
FEMINIST ISSUES AND THE
PRODUCTION OF WOMEN.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE WRITTEN SO
MUCH ABOUT WHO MAY BE A SEX WHAT
DO YOU MAKE ABOUT SEEING YOUR
ALLIES ON THE LEFT STRIKE A
PURITAN POSITION ON THESE
QUESTIONS?
A KIND OF BLEW NOAH'S OUTRAGE AT
SENSUAL PLEASURE,
PERSONAL HAPPINESS, TELLING YOU
THAT YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO
THIS OR THAT.
WHAT HE MAKE THAT?
>> THERE'S BEEN A SPLIT WITHIN
FEMINISM.
SINCE I CAN WAVE FEMINISM, THE
MEDIA HAS BEEN EXTREMELY LAZY
AND PURSUING THIS.
I BELONG TO THE PRO SEX AND
CULTURE OF FEMINISM.
I FAVOR THE LEGALIZATION OF, I
HAVE DEFENDED PORN.
ET CETERA.
THERE'S BEEN THIS ARGUMENT FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
MY BRANCH IN THE 90s THANKS TO
MADONNA SUDDENLY BURSTING ON THE
SCENES.
SHE IS FADED, AND ALL SENSE OF
HER OWN TRAJECTORY AND I AM
ASTONISHED THAT WE ARE BACK TO
FEMINIST PURITANISM AGAIN.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
IMBALANCE.
HYSTERIA, THAT IS NOTHING TO DO
WITH WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
THESE ARE NEUROTICS WHO ARE
TALKING ABOUT HATRED OF MEN, WHO
ARE POISONING THE CULTURE.
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR A
YOUNG WOMAN TO RECONCILE WITH
YOUNG MEN.
>> Tucker: YOU MIGHT NOT AGREE
DEALT WITH CAMILLE POLLY IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THE SHOW, BUT
TRUST ME ONE OF THE MOST
INTERESTING PEOPLE.